hey guys look who it is so this would be
crazy in that cyber Channel so they're
engaged now I introduced them and now
they're leaving me yet why why why do
you feel like you have to abandon the
one who brought you guys together it's
not so much it's it's not you I know it
I know Dan's always had issues with me
ever since you saw that Alyssa Fool's
Day video oh yeah I repressed it thanks
for thanks for reminding me do you
remember the first video you guys did
together secreted and you can see her
give me the line she goes like okay I
see why selfie sticks come in handy now
yeah cuz only I'm great in the shot
right now well guys I love you I'm gonna
miss the hell out of you guys yes gonna
come on the channel enough this year you
know but now that you're gonna be living
many hours away there'll be no need for
me to talk to you anymore
they're not real friends you're just
getting its first stage is just denial
then blame and anger
eventually I'll start regretting this
and you're gonna be like calling like
great you come anyway right I'm like I
don't know and then like right before
guys I'm here very now oh yeah some
registry that you met along the way
Sheriff on
no journey alright I love you guys have
fun with your new lives and your new
friends and your better a quieter
environment it's gonna be a nice
environment though welcome and why it is
different from LA but it's nice
different cuz LA kind of sucks that's
not true yeah yeah there's other parts
of LA that are worse all right goodbye
boy